this morning we're taking a deeper dive
into a story we've been following about
millions of Americans who may be exposed
to radioactive contaminants in their
drinking water report by the nonprofit
Environmental Working Group also known
as ewg found that water supplied by at
least some utilities in all 50 states
contained a known carcinogen called
radium Anna Werner is here now with a
growing focus on water safety and a good
morning to you good morning Gail well a
glass of water may be harmless enough
but communities around the country are
increasingly faced with a concerning
reality contaminants are turning up in
their drinking water and getting them
out may be a lot harder than you think
in Brandon South Dakota this week
concerns over water dealt with the
frozen kind a blizzard that dropped
several inches of snow you want to read
a book but resident Spencer shank and
his wife Laura worry more about the
liquid coming out of the tap a public
water supply that contains radium it's
something that's really concerning to us
you know unknown cancer-causing agent in
our inner water the radioactive
substance can occur naturally and it's
been in the city's water for decades and
it's not uncommon across the country an
analysis by the nonprofit environmental
working group found 170 million people
exposed to radium from drinking water in
22,000 utilities nationwide Brandan's
radium level does not exceed federal
guidelines but many health experts say
there's no safe level of that carcinogen
to get that level down to zero would
mean expensive modifications to the
city's water treatment system and City
Administrator Brian Reed says residents
would have to decide to foot that bill
we are striving to get the lowest radium
levels we can at a reasonable cost you
can probably get all the radium out of
all the water if you're willing to spend
enough money and radium is just one of
hundreds of contaminants found in
drinking water systems nationwide things
like arsenic cadmium pesticides and
metals including hexavalent chromium and
lead the approach to treating them can
from city to city state to state in
Newburgh New York the state is building
a brand-new water treatment plant to
remove a toxic chemical known as P fos
from the water supply the price tag 50
million dollars the pollution came from
a nearby Air National Guard base Martin
brand is with the state's environmental
division it's a very big deal on new
york state is leading the nation frankly
we're one of the first states in the
nation to actually regulate these
contaminants but not all cities can
afford a major overhaul of their
treatment systems so what's a consumer
to do if they want cleaner safer water
at home I think it can be really
daunting for consumers to try to
understand these issues with water so we
can do Rick Andrew works for NSF
international a group that tests and
certifies products including water
filtration system if I want to treat my
water at home how much is this gonna
cost me it's a great question and
there's really a wide wide range a
simple filtering water pitcher could be
$30 a whole house system a couple
thousand dollars and it's important to
find out from your utility which
contaminants are in your water and get
the right system it's definitely not a
one-size-fits-all thing when you start
to get into water treatment and so some
technologies are good at one type of
contaminant but they're not very
effective on others so oftentimes people
end up with a multi-stage system sounds
complicated absolutely a can be back in
Brandon the city's decisions on treating
that radium are likely to take a year or
more this is the REO system that we put
into our home but Spencer shank isn't
waiting he's installed two types of
water treatment systems in his home to
make sure his 2 year old daughter and 3
month old twins don't absorb carcinogens
along with their h2o it's frustrating
for us because we just want a clean
sustainable water source that's all
that's all we're asking for well we
checked our own water supply here in New
York City I plugged in my zip code and
found 6 contaminants that were detected
at levels either higher than the
national average or higher than some
health advisories
now ewg is one resource you can go plug
in your zip code there's simple check
you can also check your consumer
confidence report which lists what's in
your water system or you can call your
local utility to find out what's in your
water system but I did find that in some
previous places I've lived in there was
radium in those water systems which
means I was drinking it too Wow now
people are gonna plug it in everybody's
saying what's my zip code again you see
my water is okay weed out the correct
address if anybody wants to check what
that is absolutely yeah I think it's
really eye-opening for a lot of people a
lot of us have done it and we've all
been surprised you've been working on
these stories thank you and I appreciate
that